[Musik]
hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
befinde mich gerade hier in Rom Italien
sehr sehr schön und mache mich jetzt
aber auf den Weg nach Zürich aber suche
ich nämlich den Loris und auf dem Weg
dahin werden wir einiges erleben ich
habe nämlich echt coole Strecken gebucht
und wir werden einige neue Züge testen
ich befinde mich hier gerade in Roma
Hauptbahnhof ja muss mich jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen zurechtfinden weil hier ist
ganz schön viel los irgendwie sieht das
hier eher aus wie ein Flughafen finde
ich als wie ein Bahnhof also das hier
ist alles komplett runter der Bahnhof
ach komm wir gehen hier mal rein trains
hey Leute ich glaube das hier ist
wirklich der größte Bahnhof von dem ich
je war so Probleme also
ich habe echt gar keine Ahnung wo ich
hin muss aber wir finden schon oh Mann
ich hätte natürlich nach Zürich auch
einfach fliegen können aber das ist ja
zu einfach deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
wir testen einmal in schnellsten Zug in
ganzen Italienern das ist sehr karosser
da gibt's auch mittlerweile eine neuen
von den freck karosser 1000 den habe ich
leider nicht erwischt der hat nicht auf
meiner Route vielleicht ist das ach das
ist ja sogar schaut mal hier Leute der
fährt einfach 400 km/h oh mann das ist
schade den hätte ich gern genommen aber
wir können ja irgendwann später noch mal
testen ich glaube jetzt bin ich auch so
langsam endlich mal hier richtig ey
Leute das ist einfach so groß wie eine
schaut mal das geht bis da ganz hinten
befinde mich jetzt auf jeden Fall gerade
in Rom Termini ich glaube das ist der
größte Bahnhof in Rom und wie schon
gesagt werde ich von hier aus gleich 600
km bis nach Mailand fahren in den Norden
von Italien da war ich auch noch nie da
freue ich mich schon sehr drauf wie
schon gesagt ich habe diesen direkt
karosser ich hoffe ich spreche das
richtig aus zu gebucht meiner fährt wohl
bis zu 360 kmh nicht so schnell wieder
rote in seinem Hintergrund aber was
super interessant ist es gibt die zweite
Klasse es gibt die erste Klasse und es
gibt auch noch eine executive klasse
also noch besser als erste Klasse in
Deutschland gibt sowas soweit ich weiß
nicht und das habe ich natürlich gebucht
das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit
hier in die Lounge zu kommen die ich
jetzt hoffentlich noch finden werde naja
dann geht's nach Mailand ich freue mich
schon sehr ach so und morgen fahre ich
dann noch glässt ja Express durch die
Schweiz da freue ich mich auch schon
sehr drauf es wird auf jeden Fall geil
ich wünsche euch viel Spaß bei dem
Videos und ja let's go gekostet hat mich
der Spaß übrigens 155 € bist du in
Ordnung leute wenn ihr diese zugvideos
feiert dann seid doch so lieb und
abonniert den Kanal weil das haben super
super viele noch nicht gemacht da würde
ich mir extrem freuen ich bin hier
gerade schon im Hotel und jetzt geht's
weiter ah okay er kommt Alter was ist
das denn komme
das habe ich auch extra bezahlt und es
musste
Hunger wir suchen alter das ist ja
einfach so lange ich muss noch bis da
ganz hinten das ist 500 m oder so Leute
das ist viel zu groß hier aber ich habe
jetzt die Lounge gefunden
ist jetzt natürlich nichts Besonderes so
wie eure osterlounge aber trotzdem in
Ordnung nur besser als nichts da gibt's
keinen Spaghetti glaube ich zumindest
eigentlich Hunger
das ist natürlich umsonst
[Musik]
übrigens wer denkt sogar einen neuen
deutschen Verspätung 55 Minuten hat
meiner Verspätung dass der einzige aber
das wird immer mehr shit
[Musik]
so Leute mittlerweile sind fast eine
halbe Stunde rum der Zug hat gut
eineinhalb Stunden Verspätung super
ärgerlich weil jetzt ist es dunkel das
heißt ich sehe nicht mehr so viel von
der Landschaft von Italien super schade
aber finally ist da vielen Dank
okay ich bin den Wagen eins Platz 1A
also ganz vorne schauen wir mal
irgendwann ging es dann zum Glück
endlich mal los wir sind auf jeden Fall
auch nicht viele Plätze aber das ist ja
gut
1A das ist mein Platz also ich habe noch
nie einen Bahnwagen gesehen wo so wenn
ich sitze in einem Raum sind wir hier
das sind vielleicht 1 2 3 4 5 9 Stück na
ja auf jeden Fall genug Platz aber ich
habe gar keinen Tisch außerdem hier
also wie gesagt wir haben eineinhalb
Stunden Verspätung aber ich freue mich
jetzt bin ich so um 21 Uhr erst in
Mailand also der braucht für 600
Kilometer ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden
echt nicht lange ist schon krass und ja
ich freue mich jetzt auf die Fahrt ich
habe keine Ahnung kann auch sein dass
ich was zu essen bekomme das habe ich
irgendwie nicht sehen können ich habe
auf einer deutschen Seite gebucht da
stand das alles nicht und Tschüss sagen
wir checken gleich auch mal den Rest zu
ab bis später ich muss allerdings sagen
ich glaube gerade weil es dunkel war die
Strecke hat sie am Ende echt gezogen und
wir standen halt irgendwie oft ich habe
mich eigentlich gefühlt wie in
Deutschland aber halt in Italien so
Leute was zu Essen bestellt und das ist
glaube ich umsonst also denke ich immer
gar nicht so laut reden weil hier ist
Ruhebereich
Leute ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt das
Essen bestellt bin mal gespannt weil das
ist erst der zweite Zug wo ich so ein
richtiges Menü in Anfang Geschichten
bekomme der erst war der Eurostar da war
das Essen wirklich richtig richtig gut
ich kann euch mal so leicht herum zeigen
da hinter mir steht er Bree und macht
das immer Mikrowelle warm aber ich bin
einfach mal gespannt ich weiß noch nicht
so ganz auf das was kostet aber
eigentlich glaube ich nicht das wird
mich schon wundern denke es mit dem
Preis drin und dann muss ich sagen
Shampoo von geil
ich bin auch im Kaffee
[Musik]
ich habe mir dann erstmal einen Risotto
bestellt mit so ein bisschen Käse drin
da muss ich leider sagen das hat echt
nicht gut geschmeckt total wässrig aber
ja ihr könnt es ja sehen
[Musik]
und Leute wir sind uns im Florenz hier
war ich auch noch nie aber leider habe
ich keine Zeit auszusteigen übrigens
auch noch keine Ahnung wo ich heute
Nacht pennen werde aber dazu später mehr
es könnte echt noch eine lange Reise
werden muss ich sagen und ich muss halt
morgen um 8 Uhr einen Zug steigen in St
Moritz na ja ich weiß nämlich nicht ganz
ob ich heute noch bis nach St Moritz
schaffen werde wegen der Verspätung und
so dann ging es weiter ich hatte
irgendwie noch Hunger und habe mir
einfach mal ja so Käse mit so ein
bisschen Schinken und einem pinken
Brötchen bestellt das war eigentlich
ganz nice ja eher so als Vorspeise aber
ich habe es halt danach gegessen und ja
habe halt eine Cola getrunken und dann
habe ich auch ein Bier getrunken dann
habe ich noch im Wasser getrunken ein
Bologna war ich übrigens auch schon und
jetzt gleich haben wir in Mailand an
also das ist nicht mehr weit 75 km ich
würde sagen 20 Minuten sind wir da was
mein leibliches Wohl angeht habe ich
mich an Bord sehr sehr wohl gefühlt und
ich glaube das gibt's auch zu diesem
Preis und in dieser Auswahl nirgendwo
günstiger
und ich muss mir jetzt mega beeilen
damit ich noch den Anschluss bekomme
sonst kann ich heute Nacht nicht draußen
schlafen also wenn ich den nicht bekomme
wird es echt bald
okay ich sehe schon zu
g ist naja immerhin die Bahnhöfe sehen
hier alles so aus wie in Frankfurt ne
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof sieht auch so aus
so Leute ich bin jetzt zum nächsten Zug
das ist jetzt der letzte den ich nehmen
kann an die Italiener von euch die sich
auskennen weil es nach Monza da muss ich
umsteigen und dann fahre ich nach
Letscho dann letscher keine Ahnung
eigentlich weiß ich das Ganze im Norden
gefahren von Italien da hätte ich dann
Mitfahrgelegenheit gehabt nach St Moritz
nur jetzt ist schon so spät die bekomme
ich nicht mehr und jetzt muss ich gleich
wahrscheinlich mit Taxi fahren 1 Stunde
oder so naja tut mir die Daumen und dann
kriegen wir das schon hin
[Musik]
so Leute was geht da bin ich wieder ich
bin mittlerweile hier im Hotel bin auch
schon in St Moritz angekommen gestern
Abend musste aber dann einfach mal
pennen gehen habe mich jetzt ein
bisschen ausgeschlafen wir haben jetzt
gerade halb acht und mich geht's in paar
Stunden schon weiter aber die Bewertung
vom Zug steht an und das machen wir
jetzt ich hatte übrigens am Ende 95
Minuten Verspätung also kam 95 Minuten
verspätet an deswegen habe ich dann auch
mein Anschluss und so verpasst das war
ein bisschen ärgerlich es war echt nicht
gut gestern also wir merken uns es ist
nicht nur immer in Deutschland alles
verspätet wobei das gestern der einzige
Zug bei der Verspätung hatte aber gut so
starten wir mit dem Komfort ich war ja
in der exzellent Glas wir waren dort
zwischendurch zu dritt dann waren wir
auch mal zu viert aber da war eigentlich
nichts los und man hatte übelst viel
Platz die Sitze waren bequem da kann ich
überhaupt nichts gegen sagen hier auf
jeden Fall fünf von fünf Sterne machen
wir weiter mit dem Essen das fand ich
auch sehr bemerkenswert ich habe die
ganze Zeit eigentlich Essen bestellen
können also alles was ich wollte egal ob
Hauptgang oder einen Anführungsstrichen
Hauptgang Getränke Nachtisch oder
sonstiges angefangen hat sie mit diesem
Risotto das fand ich echt gar nicht gut
also das hat mir gar nicht geschmeckt
total wässrig und so hat man halt
gezeigt es ist so Mikrowellen Zeugs aber
halt wirklich nicht gut dann auch diese
Platte mit Käse und diesem pinken Brot
ich hatte auch noch einen Snack
zwischendurch das war dann in Ordnung
aber für die Qualität des Essens würde
ich einfach mal drei von fünf Sterne
geben trotzdem cool dass man das alles
umsonst und dann dazu bekommen hat
Service ganz klar 55 Sterne super
freundlich aber wir hatten zu dritt
eigentlich einen Kellner der die ganze
Zeit kam und gefragt hat ob alles in
Ordnung ist ob man noch was essen möchte
was trinken möchte das war echt super
und deswegen safe 55 Sterne
naturerlebnisfaktor ja war ein bisschen
schade durch die Verspätung war es dann
schon dunkel und ich habe nicht viel von
der italienischen Landschaft gesehen wir
sind aber viel durch lange Tunnel
gefahren auch teilweise an der Autobahn
mit entlang super schwierig
einzuschätzen im Dunkeln ich würde
einfach mal drei von fünf Sterne geben
Tendenz eher zu zwei aber ich kann es ja
nicht sagen und ich will nichts schlecht
machen was ich nicht wirklich gesehen
habe und dann haben wir noch die
Preis-Leistung ich habe 154 € bezahlt
das lag auch daran weil ich unter 26 bin
und weil ich meine Bahncard 50 angeben
konnte sonst ist das ganze noch mal ein
bisschen teurer trotzdem wenn man sich
das ja vor Augen hält in Deutschland
habe ich sowas noch nie gesehen mit so
einem guten Service ich glaube das
gibt's auch gar nicht und halt auch mit
diesen essensangeboten in der excellent
class dem ganzen Platz und so 154 € kann
man nicht meckern safe meiner Meinung
nach 55 Sterne auch die Lounge vorher wo
man sich hinstellen konnte das war schon
alles in Ordnung und ich habe mich da
sehr wohl gefühlt tschuldigung hier eine
kurze Korrektur ich meine vier von fünf
Sternen ich habe total vergessen dass
wir diese Fette Verspätung hatten und ja
deswegen muss ich einfach bei
Preis-Leistung einstellen abziehen und
deswegen haben wir jetzt hier am Ende
eine Bewertung die sich glaube ich schon
sehen lassen kann falls ich jetzt
richtig überschlagen hat müssten das 20
von 25 Sterne sein das ist schon echt in
Ordnung und ja das war der frecher rosa
aus Italien ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen mir hat Spaß gemacht waren sehr
ereignisreicher Tag gestern Leute
abonniert super gerne den Kanal und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten Video haut
rein ciao